he's one of the biggest movie stars in
Hollywood he has a net worth of a
hundred and fifty million dollars Oprah
Winfrey said in all the years of her
show he was one of their greatest
teachers he's Jim Carrey and here his
top ten rules for success who would have
thought in all of the years of the Oprah
show the Jim Carrey would be one of our
greatest teachers I think it's really a
marvelous thing that visualization thing
you did you don't do I read about this I
hear this that you used to go up on
Mulholland Drive and Park every night
and visualize seeing yourself is yeah I
would visualize uh yeah this is real
life welcome pool right having directors
interested in me and people that I
respected saying you know I like your
work or whatever that is and and I would
visualize things coming to me that I
wanted or whatever this was in like
nineteen eighty seven eighty five yeah
and I had nothing at that time so it was
like but it just made me feel better it
made me at that time all it really was
for me was kind of making me feel better
I would drive home and think well I do
have these things and they're out there
I just don't have ahold of them yet but
they're out there so didn't you write
yourself a check I heard that you did is
that true wrote myself a check for ten
million dollars for acting services
rendered and I gave myself five years
there were three years maybe and and I
dated it Thanksgiving 1995 and I put it
in my wallet and I kept it there and it
deteriorated and deteriorated and stuff
and and but then just before
Thanksgiving 1995 I found out that I was
gonna make ten million dollars on
thinking food Dumb and Dumber
when I say life doesn't happen to you it
happens for you I really don't know if
that's true
I'm just making a conscious choice to
perceive challenges as something
beneficial so that I can deal with them
in the most productive way you'll come
up with your own style that's part of
the fun
all my life I've really wanted to do
this so it doesn't seem like I've been
in the business for a short time that's
all I've ever wanted to do it's all I've
ever done just this insane belief in my
own ability to manifest things insane a
belief you know that I think it's
ultimately complete sanity but I believe
we're creators and I believe we create
with every thought and every word is
every moment is pregnant with the next
moment of your life you will already
know who you are and that piece that
piece that we're after lies somewhere
beyond personality your need for
acceptance can make you invisible in
this world don't let anything stand in
the way of the light that shines through
this form risk being seen in all of your
glory
I have no education I had no high school
diploma I didn't even have a GED I quit
high school and halfway through grade
ten I didn't have a lot of options that
would be a dishwasher or a waiter
custodial work of some sort so I decided
I might as well go and do something
creative I decided to go to the Comedy
Store laugh factoring The Improv you
know all all of those clubs every night
and make my twenty five bucks a pop a
set was my version of being a waiter it
was a compromise I decided to make out
of that came in living color and out of
that came touring auditoriums 5,000
seaters it was a really creative time
I was able to prove that I didn't have
to be an impressionist that I had a
personality of my own and however
abrasive it might be from time to time a
long story short all of it came from
that compromise from that deciding to do
what I didn't want to do things you
can't do or the things you're not
allowed to do look at the executives
come and say you can't do that whatever
it is it's too expensive you get angry
you get out of your mind about it
because you've been clinging to this
concept in this image that you have of
how it should be done and invariably
most times after that storm has passed
and you actually sit down and go okay we
can't do it that way how can we do it
you end up with something even better
than what was there before and you go
that's the universe that's how it works
just like relationships like everything
the thing that has taken away if you're
clinging to it you're trying to fix it
you're trying to secure it make sure it
doesn't go away you think it your life
will be destroyed everything will be
ruined and it's just universe going no I
have something better for you just have
faith sometimes compromise is actually
the way to get to what you want you are
ready and able to do beautiful things in
this world and after you walk through
those doors today you will only ever
have two choices love or fear choose
love and don't ever let fear turn you
against your playful heart a total
believer yeah I believe in manifestation
I believe in you know putting a rocket
of desire out into the universe and and
you get it when you believe it you get
it when you believe you have it and
that's the key is like people still they
sit around going when's it going to come
when's it going to come when's it going
to come when's it going to come and
that's the wrong way you're you're faced
in the wrong way you're facing away from
it you have to go it's here it's here
it's here
it's our intention our intention is
everything nothing happens on this
planet without it not one single thing
has ever been accomplished without
intention you can spend your whole life
imagining ghosts worrying about the
pathway to the future but all there will
ever be is what's happening here in the
decisions we make in this moment which
are based in either love or fear so many
of us choose our path out of fear
disguised as practicality what we really
want seems impossibly out of reach and
ridiculous to expect so we never dare to
ask the universe for it I'm saying I'm
the proof that you can ask the universe
for it please
and if it doesn't happen for you right
away it's only because the universe is
so busy fulfilling my order
my father could have been a great
comedian but he didn't believe that that
was possible for him and so he made a
conservative choice instead he got a
safe job as an accountant and when I was
12 years old he was let go from that
safe job and our family had to do
whatever we could to survive I learned
many great lessons from my father not
the least of which was that you can fail
at what you don't want so you might as
well take a chance on doing what you
love thank you so much for watching I
made this video because Danielle
Grantham asked me to so if there's a
famous entrepreneur that you want me to
profile leave a comment below let me
know who it is and I just might make a
video on thank you for watching continue
to believe and I'll see you soon